do you have problems in your life that
you're not addressing that you could
solve an answer is yet and it's an easy
thing to figure out you sit on your bed
one morning and say okay there's some
things that need to be done that I don't
want to do that I could do that would
make things better by the end of the day
what are they well your your conscience
will deliver those suckers no time flat
now and then you might have to say okay
well how do i entice myself into doing a
few of those and if you ask instead of
trying to force yourself to do it like
you're a tyrant and a slave at the same
time you can usually negotiate with
yourself so that you'll start to sort
those things out sort them out put your
house in order
and then move out move on and out yeah
that's a Freudian slip by the way
yeah so it's important because the thing
is you have a practice still made right
there are there are things that are
within your graph that you can fix fix
them and you'll learn you'll learn tis
it's harder than it looks
fix them and you'll learn how to fix
things and then something else will
beckon as another problem that you could
fix you know you all have your problem
what does that mean like there's an
infinite number of problems in the world
some of them happen to be yours why is
that I don't know exactly but you have
your problems great solve them you know
one of the thing I learned as a
therapist every therapist has to learn
this is because one of the things you
wonder when you're first starting to be
a clinician is how do you not take the
catastrophes of your clients home with
you and the answer to that is because
it's immoral to they're not your
problems they're their problems but
they're they're their life you know your
problems are your life you don't want to
solve someone else's problems for them
because you take away the deep meaning
that's to be found in having them work
through the problems on their own and
then you steal the credit well I can
help you with that it's like well yeah
maybe but I don't help you with the next
problem then so in any case you sort
sort out the problems that are right in
front of you and you will it will make
you grow very very rapidly and then
you'll be able to sort out more complex
problems without making the work